From toys coated with lead paint...
...to tainted milk, to contaminated pet food.
These images have shaped what it means to be "Made in China".
Cheap, made very inexpensively...
...and I guess, there are some quality issues that nag at the back of your mind.
With a 30-second TV commercial, China is trying to change years of bad press.
Commissioned by China's Commerce Ministry and four major industry groups.
This commercial is believed to be the government's first bid at global branding.
An offshoot of an American ad agency made it.
The TV spot highlights Chinese products made with worldwide partners.
I think it's reasonably sophisticated for Western audiences.
I think it has a modern feel.
International media consultant, Tapio Christiansen has worked with Chinese companies.
He says, the commercial is necessary after melamine tainted milk produced in China...
...killed at least six Chinese children and made hundreds of thousands sick.
They did a pretty decent job in trying to potentially dispel...
...some of the perceptions that some in the West have about Chinese goods.